you're going to go
down might as well go down
[Music]
swinging
hey there folks as you may or may not
know the channel Nando V movies for the
last couple years has been doing these
pseudo collaborations where he presents
a theme of one certain kind of scene
there done one marvelous scene one
villainous scene I participated in one
last year one musical scene where a
certain specific type of scene is
highlighted and he and other channels
familiar with him put out videos and
even those who don't know him but
channels that are smaller like mine or
even smaller still can put out a video
in that same theme and it'll get added
to the playlist so whether you're
finding me on that playlist or because
you already follow my stuff welcome this
time it's one last scene fitting as this
is the last one Nando movies intends to
actually organize himself someone else
might pick up the torch uh in future
it's hard to say but for right now this
might be the end of this particular uh
project and it is intended to talk about
endings now Nando uh did say in his own
video that these don't have to be the
literal final scene of a film that
having been said that's absolutely what
I'm going to focus on and I wanted to
narrow down on a very specific type of
ending and I knew that's what I wanted
to do I just had to figure out what I
was going to use as my example for the
type of ending I want to talk about an
Abrupt ending an ending that you did not
think it was G to end there and it just
cut to Black we're
done and there are some marvelous
examples and there are absolutely
examples of it going very badly abrupt
endings are tricky the key to a good
abrupt ending in my opinion is ending it
at a moment in the story where by
stopping right there says something and
makes a point by the fact that you chose
to end there it brings attention to
something that might have been lost or
not properly appreciated had the film or
show continued on to a more standard
resolution and Dena or Koda or you know
sort of wrap up like no hard stop right
there and the way to do it right is to
have that stop make a point so as I said
I considered a number of things I
considered Inception I considered the
final episode of the show Angel but I am
going to focus on the movie The Gray
directed by Joe carahan and starring
Liam niss this movie came out in 2012
and by its nature I'm going to be
talking about the ending so spoilers if
you hadn't guessed that already this is
a film that focuses on a man named awe
and he has been running Security on an
oil rig out in Alaska and Security in
this case primarily means keeping the
Wolves Away and he is a man not at a
good point in his life now his return
plane crashes so he and his co-workers
are stuck dealing with the elements the
cold the lack of supplies and the
Wolves now there are absolutely
criticisms to be made towards this movie
particularly in its depictions of wolves
it shows them as more aggressive than is
realistic it leans into the alpha thing
which has been debunked for who knows
how long I'm far more forgiving of that
particular issue here though because it
actually has a particular story purpose
that for that whereas often when I see
it it's just like you didn't even need
to perpetuate that misinformation here I
understand why it can bug some people
cuz normally it bugs me but no there's a
point and that point is as we approach
the end because this is ultimately a men
versus nature story and while I've
certainly got nothing against men versus
nature stories they're not something I
gravitate towards if for no other reason
then they tend to fall under the
category of what I what I usually kind
of think of as men movies and some of
those I can like every now and then but
as a whole something with that energy
not usually my jam uh not at this point
in my life H I wonder why
but even with that sense which is there
somewhat because this is an all male
cast them battling the
elements but it's not about triumphing
over nature it's actually not even
really about the fact that you can't
triumph over nature the fact that it's
Man versus his nature isn't the
point what is the point well the ending
makes the point very very
clear as the film has continued all of
the men who survived the plane crash one
by one something happens they get picked
off by Wolves they suffer an injury that
they can't recover from one gets trapped
underwater in a river and drowns and
eventually only awe is
left and he's left carrying the wallets
of the men who didn't make it the
intention being that when he got back he
could say these are the ones who didn't
make it but he's cold he's wet he's in
the wilderness he doesn't know exactly
where he is on a map he couldn't tell
you where he
is but he's still standing and there's
been a recurring thing something that
has come been coming back there's
actually been a couple one was images of
his wife another was a memory of a poem
that his father wrote his father who was
not a poet but he wrote these words once
more into the
phas it's the last good fight I'll ever
know live and die on this day
live and die on this day so as he's
arranging these wallets on the ground
and he remembers his wife he remembers
her last words to him before she died of
a terminal
illness don't be
afraid he realizes where he
is he hasn't been moving further away
from the
Wolves he has stumbled into their
den and
now he only has one choice left to make
whether or not he's going to fight and
the poem comes back one more
time die on this day because it's going
to be
both this is going to be a day where
he's going to die most
likely but it's a day that he can also
choose to live and this matters because
earlier in the film he was having
suicidal ideation he was considering
ending his own life but here he is
facing down near certain
death and what does he do
instead he grabs what supplies he has
small liquor bottles puts those between
his fingers tapes them down tapes a
knife into his other hand smashes the
bottles he has weapons in his hand that
he can't
drop and he prepares to face down that
alpha wolf this is why I'm forgiving of
the alpha thing by the way having it
boiled down to a single opponent in that
ending moment does actually make the
story better than it would have been had
it been a pack having it narrowed down
to this one-onone confrontation
amplifies the
story and it cuts
out
just as he lunges forward to
fight does he kill the wolf does the
wolf kill him do they both die does he
somehow Against All Odds survive doesn't
matter doesn't matter I mean
statistically odds are no matter what
he's probably going to die just given
the situation he's in even if it wasn't
with the Wolves there he was probably
going to die but putting him in a
confrontation with the Wolves makes the
point that his
choice is to either give up or keep
fighting not because you'll
win but because choosing to fight means
something making the choice choice to
fight no matter what is going to happen
that is a choice you can always
make you can't
control whether or not you will live or
die you can choose whether or not you're
going to fight and by cutting it at this
exact moment that makes the point cuz it
doesn't
matter how any of this goes from here
the only thing that matters is that he
chose to fight that choice and the
instant in which it is clear Which
choice he made that is the absolute
correct moment to end to finish to go
that is why we are telling the story
that is the point that we want to make
the choice to fight is what is important
not whether or not you can win not
whether or not you survive but that
choice that choice
matters and the thing is they could have
shown more we know it was filmed Joe
caran himself has said that additional
footage uh for the fight was shot but he
claims he never intended to use it he
certainly never did whether it was a
choice made in the editing how much of
this do we show and they made the
correct choice to cut it where it was or
he as he currently claims always
intended it to end it right there but
just shot some extra stuff basically as
DVD extras or whatever which for the
record were never released but we still
know it stuff was shot because in the
trailers there's a few tiny flashes of
both him and the Wolf charging each
other and yes there's also the mid
credit scene where like you kind of see
their bodies and the Wolf is kind of
breathing but they're both laying there
I think the presumption is meant to be
that they are both dying but honestly
that mid credit scene doesn't matter
that comes later because the actual
important point the point at which you
stop the story and run the credits is
his choice to Lunge for forward and to
fight I first of all very much support
this
message you can't win every fight some
fights you will absolutely lose in the
end we're all going to have a day that
we don't see the other side
of but you still have that
choice every
time do you
stop do you let it
end
or do you stare death down and tell him
to wait his goddamn turn and maybe it is
his turn but to pull a line from a once
great TV show and that is only one thing
we say to
death not today but the thing is
eventually today will
come and one day no matter what you say
that will be it but you can still
choose you can
still make your point plant your
feet
do the thing that you're about to stop
doing which is to live you can choose to
live even on the day that you die you
can still choose to live live and die on
this day hey folks it's ver during the
edit I just want to jump in here and say
one real quick that while I very much
feel this is a strong message for the
movie to have I want to take a second to
point out I'm not touting this as some
sort of great life philosophy I don't
think people who are tired of fighting
and who make the choice to not keep
fighting are somehow inferior or weak or
deficient or anything of that nature I
just wanted to say that cuz I don't want
my praising of this film and how well it
sticks the landing of its own message to
be taken as me endorsing a specific view
of Life as a whole cool back to to it I
adore this ending I adore this movie
largely because of the ending the movie
was fine up to that point like again
it's a good man versus nature story it's
well
executed but when that ending
happened I thought to myself this is
amazing some things are truly made by
their endings and
this is the perfect ending for this
story for the point that it was
making and people should have seen it
coming as he's w the tape around his
hands it's not intense here comes the
fight music it's
[Music]
melancholic because the point isn't the
fight the point is the choice this is
music to accompany a choice not music to
accompany a fight if you want to see the
difference again you can look to the
trailers where they showed some of this
[Music]
stuff that's music to prep for a fight
but it's not about the fight it's about
the
choice and I made the choice to
highlight this particular film while it
is not the only example of a brilliantly
done abrupt
ending it is one of my favorites and
it's the one I wanted to highlight for
this have you seen this particular movie
what other abrupt endings do you really
like I mentioned some others for me
Inception we don't get to see whether or
not the top falls cuz whether or not the
top falls doesn't matter what matters is
he made the choice he made the choice
that this would be his reality so that's
certainly one what are some others what
are some of your favorite endings in
general but I'd love to hear some more
abrupt endings maybe um at the top of
your comments give a spoiler warning for
whatever it is you're going to say but
that's kind of the nature of the beast
on the topic like this whatever your
thoughts thoughts are drop them down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills enables me to do this as
my living even if you can't help me out
that way you know all the YouTube things
you know what they are but what I really
want you to remember is that whether you
choose to fight or whether you have
chosen I need to
stop whatever choice you make on any
given day you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is a
[Music]
journ drum roll for my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Z Thea
goddess Ela Oliver B to rock the thing
that goes dink in the anime Ruth go of
the gazarian solitary pictures ol RI
Bogden geek filter Linda Walters Toby
Jackson Jen Auntie Kate 8808 Bey Sparks
bomi likes the poodle Robin Powell t
love czy scrapit Angry caspel Dave Hall
quite bearish Rosalyn Bennett pal baraba
jle and miror G thanks so
[Music]
[Applause]
much
[Music]
o